Trascrizione: Beatrice Romano'
Revisore: Sofia Ramundo
(Applausi)
Noi siamo le storie che ricordiamo.
E allora dobbiamo cominciare
da una storia.
Le storie che attraversano
il tempo e lo spazio
sono le storie che ci definiscono.
Questa storia comincia in mare.
È un mare mosso,
c'è una barca che lo sta solcando.
I marinai remano a fatica,
sanno che il mare è morte,
perché nell'Odissea il mare è morte.
È attraversamento dell'ignoto,
è definizione del mondo e di sé stessi.
Legato all'albero di questa nave
c'è l'eroe che tutti conosciamo,
Ulisse.
A un certo punto, improvvisamente,
in questo mare mosso
si fa calma piatta, bonaccia.
E la paura coglie qualsiasi marinaio
che sa che, se non c'è un filo di vento,
arrivare in porto diventa difficile.
E in questo silenzio, quasi mistico,
si sente un sussurro.
Sono voci di donne, dolcissime.
Sono le voci di donne
che hanno un corpo ben strano.
Il loro corpo non è come quello
che ci siamo immaginati
con i cartoni animati.
È un corpo di uccelli,
ma la loro voce è dolcissima.
E promettono di raccontare
ai marinai di questa barca
che cosa succede sulla terra.
E in particolare,
che cosa è successo
durante la guerra di Troia.
Ora voi dovete dirmi - tutti sapete
che sto parlando delle sirene di Ulisse -
che razza di tentazione è questa?
Uno che sta tornando -
almeno ci sta provando,
è 20 anni che ci prova,
a tornare dalla guerra di Troia;
tu come promessa gli dici,
come tentazione gli dici:
"Io ti racconterò quello
che tu hai già vissuto".
Capite che è una tentazione ben strana.
E perché questo nostro eroe
si è legato all'albero della nave
e vuole ascoltare esattamente questo canto
che riguarda la storia
da cui lui sta venendo?
Per sapere se quella storia
è entrata nella Storia.
Nel mondo greco,
entrare nel racconto epico
significa avere finalmente un'identità.
Ogni cultura si struttura
attorno a questa grande sfida:
come facciamo a non far cadere
il nostro nome nel nulla.
La nascita è un accadere
che non ci siamo scelti,
e la nostra più grande paura
è che ritorneremo nel nulla
da cui siamo venuti.
Ulisse vuole sapere se il suo nome
è finalmente entrato nella Storia;
e questo vale la pena di una tentazione
come quella delle sirene.
Ma quando la nave
affianca l'isola delle sirene,
quello che c'è attorno agli scogli
sono solo ossa di uomini.
Tutti noi qua dentro
abbiamo questo stesso problema.
La mattina ci alziamo,
e cerchiamo una ragione, una prestazione
attraverso la quale finalmente
possiamo essere qualcuno.
E questo genera in noi
quella paura di vivere -
quella stanchezza di vivere,
come la chiama un filosofo.
Perché? Perché abbiamo trasformato
il nostro Io in una prestazione.
Le nostre vite assomigliano
a delle cipolle:
abbiamo tanti strati con cui cerchiamo
di definire la nostra identità,
ma il nucleo profondo
non si sa dove sia andato a finire.
Io sono di questa città,
io faccio questo lavoro,
e cerchiamo di costruire,
sulla periferia del nostro Io,
[un']identità,
in modo che il nostro essere
non cada nel nulla.
Perché ve lo ripeto,
noi abbiamo un unico problema:
come si fa a non far cadere
le cose nel nulla.
E questo ci fa paura.
Questo ci stanca.
E ogni cultura trova la sua soluzione.
Quando incontro
i genitori dei miei alunni,
le rare volte in cui vengono entrambi -
perché sembra che l'educazione, oggi,
sia demandata solo alle mamme:
cari papà, venite a parlare
con noi insegnanti,
i vostri figli saranno fieri
del fatto che avete preso
un'ora di permesso per loro -
dico loro: "Ah, adesso capisco".
Che cosa? Perché vostro figlio è così.
(Risate)
Perché i vostri figli non assomigliano
a ciascuno di voi preso singolarmente.
Assomigliano alla relazione
che c'è fra voi.
Perché l'unico modo che ha l'uomo
di nascere, e di rinascere sempre,
è essere generato.
E solo quando c'è una relazione,
c'è un principio che fa nascere
nuovo quel nucleo di essere
che ci consente quella
permanenza nell'esistenza,
che non dipende da cose
che continuamente ci sfuggono.
E finalmente potremo tirare
un sospiro di sollievo.
Per questo è importante
l'appello al mattino.
Io credo che la più grande rivoluzione
nella scuola contemporanea,
soprattutto quella italiana,
dipenda da come facciamo l'appello.
La natura, per gli animali,
provvede al fatto che tirino fuori
corazze, artigli, zanne
per potere sopravvivere nell'ambiente
in cui il cucciolo d'animale
da subito deve arrangiarvisi.
E perché invece il cucciolo d'uomo
ci mette così tanto tempo ad arrangiarsi?
Perché il cucciolo di uomo
è contro-evolutivo.
Mantiene la sua fragilità,
perché la fragilità obbliga
gli altri uomini alla cura.
È questo che ci differenzia dagli animali.
I nostri artigli, le nostre corazze,
le nostre zanne,
stanno qui e qui.
La relazione è dare all'altro
ciò di cui l'altro ha bisogno.
Quando bevete un bicchiere d'acqua,
[e] vi dissetate,
siete entrati in contatto
con una relazione:
la cosa più semplice, H2O.
2 atomi di Idrogeno e 1 di Ossigeno,
è una relazione, ciascuno dà all'altro
ciò di cui l'altro ha bisogno.
Ed è solo la relazione che genera
e rigenera una persona.
In un'epoca in cui ci illudiamo
di poter guadagnare tempo,
e lottiamo per guadagnare il tempo -
espressione assurda,
come se noi non fossimo parte del tempo,
noi non abbiamo il tempo a disposizione,
siamo a disposizione del tempo.
L'unica maniera di guadagnare tempo
è crescere,
e l'unica maniera di crescere
è nascere sempre nuovi.
Allora io mi sono divertito
a ridefinire le età della vita,
ne "L'arte di essere fragili",
a partire proprio da questo elemento.
È invalsa ormai quest'idea
che le tappe della vita
siano su una linea retta:
c'è un inizio e poi,
per un principio quasi inerziale,
arriveremo ai titoli di coda.
E allora siamo lì che lottiamo
per conquistare quella permanenza,
per sapere se siamo entrati
nel grande racconto.
E se ci fosse un'altra soluzione?
Se potessimo veramente essere felici
senza doverlo dimostrare a nessuno?
Non sarà che l'essere vivente
vive nella misura
in cui è generato e rigenerato?
E allora, generare questi vostri figli
non avviene una volta per tutte.
Avviene in ogni santo giorno
in cui qualcuno decide
di mettere di nuovo al mondo
quella persona.
Soltanto così guadagniamo tempo,
e facciamo guadagnare tempo agli altri,
perché non smettiamo di crescere
e di farli crescere.
La vita non assomiglia a una linea retta,
assomiglia a una spirale;
tutte le volte
che noi siamo vicini al centro
che genera questo nucleo di novità
che ciascuno di noi è -
perché nascere è essere
un inedito al mondo,
nessuno di noi qua dentro
ha le impronte digitali uguali,
nessuno di noi
ha l'iride degli occhi uguale.
Tanto che, ormai,
i nostri oggetti tecnologici
ci riconoscono così.
E noi amiamo Siri e amiamo Cortana;
guardiamo quello schermo, in media,
200 volte al giorno.
Immaginatevi di guardare
200 volte al giorno
vostro figlio o vostra figlia.
Così, all'improvviso, per 200 volte.
Dice, ma sei scemo?
(Risate)
No!
È che sei importante!
È che non c'è stato mai niente come te,
sulla faccia della Terra.
È esattamente quello che noi
cerchiamo, da quegli oggetti:
che sappiano che noi siamo unici.
Ma non c'è un altro modo di saperlo?
Si, ma è faticoso.
La vita è una spirale:
più siamo vicini
a questo centro, mentre avanza,
più la nostra vita vive e si amplia;
più ci allontaniamo,
la nostra vita si disgrega.
E qual è, allora,
il modo in cui le tappe
della vita si realizzano?
Io mi sono divertito,
attraverso le parole di un poeta,
a ridefinirle,
perché non c'entrano niente
con una linea retta.
Che cos'è dell'adolescenza che noi
dobbiamo mantenere per tutta la vita?
Che cos'è della maturità che noi
E allora ho ridefinito la vita
in questo modo:
l'adolescenza come arte di sperare;
la maturità come arte di morire;
la terza età, o riparazione,
come arte di essere fragili;
e l'ultima, morire, o arte di rinascere.
Nell'adolescenza quello che accade -
perché è l'arte di sperare?
Perché per la prima volta
emerge il copione inedito
che ciascuno di questi ragazzi
è venuto a raccontare.
E non c'è più la facile soluzione,
dettata dal piacere o dall'obbligo,
che è tipica del bambino,
che tutto ciò che vuole
lo ottiene con il pianto.
L'inedito finalmente viene alla luce,
ed è il motivo per cui
un ragazzo, una ragazza,
sente per la prima volta
che la libertà è nelle sue mani.
Ed è pronto a rompere qualsiasi muro,
purché quell'inedito si realizzi.
Ed è questo che rende un ragazzo
protagonista della sua vita.
Protagonista è una parola
bellissima, antica
che indica colui
che combatte in prima fila,
colui che combatte per primo.
Ma nessuno combatte
se non ha un motivo per cui combattere.
E l'adolescenza è il momento
in cui quell'ardore,
che noi possiamo chiamare rapimento,
vocazione, come volete voi,
finalmente entra nell'esistenza.
Attraverso la relazione con il mondo
capiamo cosa siamo venuti a portare.
Io mi ricordo quando
il mio insegnante di lettere
mi chiamò e mi disse:
"Alessandro, questo è
il mio libro di poesie preferito.
Te lo presto, fra due settimane
me lo restituisci".
Io quel giorno sono diventato insegnante.
Perché quell'insegnante
mi confidava il suo segreto,
vedeva in me qualche cosa che io
davanti allo specchio non potevo vedere;
ecco cos'è quell'appello.
È il fatto che nel mio sguardo,
quando chiamo quel nome,
loro devono vedere
che io intuisco, amorevolmente,
già la storia che si compierà.
Non la conosco,
ma so che il mio credo
ha come argomenti di fede -
professore vuol dire professare,
i nomi e i cognomi di quei ragazzi.
Per questo quei nomi e cognomi
sono più importanti della lezione.
E poi inizia la seconda fase:
pieni di questo ardore,
di questo slancio vocazionale,
pensiamo che il mondo ci stia aspettando.
La maturità è allora l'arte di morire,
perché uno dopo l'altro invece accadrà
che verrà smontato tutto ciò
che pensiamo di dover portare al mondo.
E che nessuno ci sta aspettando.
Ma siccome ci siamo svincolati
dal principio di piacere del bambino,
sappiamo e impariamo che quel fuoco
si nutre degli ostacoli che incontra.
Immaginatevi Michelangelo che,
di fronte a un blocco di marmo.
osasse dire:
"Che noia questo marmo
di Carrara, è così duro".
(Risate)
E invece è proprio quella durezza,
quella resistenza,
che ci consegna dei capolavori
come quelli che ha fatto Michelangelo.
Ma capite che questo libera un adolescente
da quella pretesa,
quel delirio narcisistico
che è tipico poi di chi rimane bambino,
di non esplorare il mondo
perché non c'è niente da esplorare;
ma di usare il mondo semplicemente
per una propria conferma.
Esplora il mondo solo chi ha trovato
una ragione per morire al mondo.
Allora la maturità è arte di morire
senza perdere quell'ardore
dell'adolescenza.
E si entra allora nella terza età,
la riparazione, o arte di essere fragili,
che dipende da una sola cosa,
dalla qualità delle relazioni
che noi abbiamo
con il mondo e con gli altri.
Dire "Ti amo" a una persona
ormai è diventato troppo semplice.
Provate a scrivere ogni tanto,
al posto di "Ti amo":
"Tu non devi morire,
e io mi impegnerò
perché questo non accada."
Ve lo ripeto:
tu non devi morire,
e io mi impegnerò
perché questo non accada.
Amare una persona
è farsi custodi del suo destino,
come quell'insegnante
che mi prestò il libro quel giorno.
Perché quella mattina,
quell'insegnante non stava pensando
all'ennesima giornata
di scuola noiosa da affrontare
e a degli alunni fastidiosi da sopportare.
Nella sua biblioteca,
ha tirato fuori il libro
che poteva servire al suo alunno.
Perché la relazione si cura
quando si dà all'altro
ciò di cui l'altro ha bisogno.
E ci si prende cura del mondo così
solo quando si ha qualche cosa
da portare nel mondo.
Se io oggi a 40 anni
sono un insegnante felice,
è perché a 17 anni un uomo mi ha prestato
il suo libro di poesie preferito.
Sembra che io stia raccontando l'acqua,
la cosa più semplice.
Ma l'acqua è una relazione, H2O.
Dare all'altro
ciò di cui l'altro ha bisogno.
E allora poi potremmo permetterci, anche,
di entrare nella fase finale
della nostra vita,
ma tanto non è quella finale.
Morire, o arte di rinascere,
è proprio questo:
quando una persona sa
qual è l'inedito che è venuto
a scrivere su questa Terra.
La lotta che fa ogni giorno
per realizzarlo,
negli altri prima che in se stesso,
è ciò che gli garantisce di aver fatto
qualcosa di bello al mondo,
che sia conosciuta o no
dagli altri non importa.
E allora tutte le volte
che faccio l'appello,
quello che dovrei fare
è mettermi in ginocchio
di fronte a quei 20-25 volti,
che sono proprio il mondo
che mi viene affidato.
La prima volta che Ulisse
entra in scena nell'Odissea
sta piangendo.
Perché gli eroi veri hanno le lacrime,
Più di tutti.
E perché sta piangendo?
Perché ha nostalgia di Itaca,
di sua moglie,
di suo figlio, di suo padre.
Calipso, la dea immortale e bellissima,
se ne stupisce
e gli chiede: perché piangi?
Perché sei fragile? Perché sei mortale?
E Ulisse risponde,
perché casa mia è oltre questo mare.
E lei dice: ma rimani con me!
Io ti renderò immortale.
E poi sono molto più bella di Penelope.
Gentile, Calipso.
Queste dee che non sanno cos'è la morte,
e non sanno neanche cos'è amare.
E Ulisse risponde:
"È vero, tu sei più bella di Penelope.
Ma lei è mia moglie, è lei che ho scelto".
E per questo Ulisse
sceglie la mortalità,
sceglie la fragilità,
sceglie un'isola piccola
e abbastanza inospitale.
Perché lì l'aspettano
il figlio Telemaco, il padre Laerte,
la moglie Penelope.
E per questo lo ricorderemo
nei secoli dei secoli.
Perché ciò che definisce la nostra vita
è ciò che noi sappiamo amare.
Ciò che definisce la nostra vita
E allora mi piace chiudere
con i versi di un poeta,
morto a 50 anni di cancro,
che ha voluto
che sulla sua tomba ci fosse scritto
quello che aveva vergato
nei versi della sua ultima poesia.
"Hai avuto quello che volevi
dalla vita, nonostante tutto?
Si.
E che cosa volevi?
Volevo potermi dire amato,
volevo sentirmi amato sulla Terra.
Ciò che sappiamo amare
è ciò che non ci sarà strappato.
è la nostra eredità, il resto è scoria.
Ciò che sappiamo amare
è la nostra storia".
(Applausi)